[Music]
[Music]
tom clancy was born on april 12 1947 in
baltimore maryland
his father thomas clancy was a mail
carrier for the united states postal
service and his mother catherine clancy
worked in the credit department of the
store
an irish-american family clancy was the
middle child of their family of five
growing up in the northwood neighborhood
in northeast baltimore
clancy attended loyola high school in
towson maryland
after his graduation in 1965 he
furthered his education at the
associated loyola college
while at college clancy joined the army
reserve officers training corps his
lifelong dream however he was ineligible
to serve due to his poor eyesight
but regardless he maintained an interest
in the military and continued to
research various aspects of the armed
forces and military technology
in 1969 he graduated with a bachelor's
degree in english literature
clancy went on to work for an insurance
company in hartford connecticut
in the same year clancy married wanda
thomas king a nursing student who'd
later become an eye surgeon
they would go on to have three daughters
and a son
in 1973 clancy joined the of bowen
agency a small insurance agency based in
maryland that was founded by his wife's
grandfather
in 1980 he purchased the insurance
agency
having always dreamed of writing a novel
this was the time he would begin writing
his debut novel in his spare time
upon the completion of his first novel
called the hunt for red october clancy
sold it for publishing to the naval
institute press for five thousand
dollars
this book introduced the character of
jack ryan
the publisher was impressed with the
work stating that they believed it was a
potential best seller
clancy's initial hopes were that he
would sell 5 000 copies of the book
however far exceeding his expectations
the hunt for red october passed the 45
000 unit mark becoming an instant hit
but it wouldn't end here
later on after receiving it as a
christmas gift president ronald reagan
would praise the novel calling it the
perfect yarn
this would boost the sales to over 300
000 hardcover and 2 million paperback
copies of the book making it a national
bestseller
after the success of the book he became
a sought after name in literary circles
the book was critically praised for its
technical accuracy which in turn led to
clancy meeting several high-ranking
officers in the u.s military
the success of this novel led to his
insurance career taking a back seat as
he focused more on writing
over time clancy became renowned for his
novels that focused on the hero that was
highly skilled disciplined honest
thoroughly professional and would only
lose the call when incompetent
politicians or bureaucrats got in their
way
their unambiguous triumphs over evil
provide symbolic relief from the legacy
of the vietnam war
the next 20 years would see him release
a plethora of written work
which would include stories such as red
storm rising patriot games clear and
present danger without remorse executive
orders
and rainbow six
seventeen of his novels would make it to
the top of the new york times bestseller
list
by 1988 clancy had earned 1.3 million
for the hunt of red october and had
signed a three million dollar contract
for his next three books
in 1992 he sold the north american
rights to without remorse for 14 million
dollars
a record for a single book
in 1995 clancy and his wife wanda
briefly separated
however in 1996 they proceeded to follow
through with wander filing for divorce
in november 1997.
this would become final in january 1999.
six months later clancy married
freelance journalist alexandra marie
luellen who he had known since 1997.
the couple had one daughter together
tom clancy would go on to co-author a
number of memoirs of top generals and
had numerous guided tours of the elite
aspects of the american military
american historian andrew basovich would
later state clancy did for military pop
lit what starbucks did for the
preparation of caffeinated beverages
he launched a sprawling massively
profitable industrial enterprise that
simultaneously serves and cultivates an
insatiable consumer base
whether the item consumed provides much
in terms of nourishment is utterly
beside the point
that it tastes yummy going down more
than suffices to keep customers coming
back
in 1996 after six years of development
clancy would release tom clancy's ssn in
cooperation with virtus studios
a video game based on one of his books
using the same name
the day after its release clancy and
virtus announced the formation of
redstorm entertainment a name derived
from the clancybook redstorm rising
clancy would take the role of chairman
it was reported that by 1997 penguin
putnam incorporated paid clancy and
redstorm for two new books and a
four-year multimedia deal for 97 million
dollars
also in 1997 redstorm released its first
game tom clancy's
political redstorm quickly gained
recognition through games like dominant
species one of the first real-time
strategy games available in the market
but it was rainbow six released in 1998
that would firmly establish the company
in the industry
rainbow six was the first true tactical
shooter where the user was required to
use patience and planning
a complete contrast to other run and gun
shooters available at the time
in august of 2000 while working on the
first game in the ghost recon series
french video game publisher ubisoft
purchased redstorm entertainment
by 2008 ubisoft would also acquire the
use of the tom clancy name to be used in
conjunction with video games and other
multimedia
fox news alert with some very sad news
to report the best-selling author tom
clancy has died
in 2013 following years of heart
complications including a heart attack
and bypass surgery on october 1st tom
clancy died of heart failure at john
hopkins hospital
he was 66 years old leaving behind his
five children and wife alexandra
[Music]
tom clancy's written work has been felt
far beyond the publishing world
some became hollywood blockbusters
starring actors like harrison ford alec
baldwin and ben affleck
some were turned into video games that
were so realistic at the time that the
military licensed them for training
in fact the detail that his books would
go into on soviet submarines weaponry
satellites and fighter planes raised a
number of suspicions and concerns among
u.s military officials
but this was just clancy's style
he spent years researching technical
manuals and interviewing military
experts
the absolute detail was what drove his
novels
critics have since spoken of clancy's
work stating that it was him that was
able to redefine and expand on the genre
allowing many others to publish such
books that were previously unable to
i thought given the amount of time i've
invested into tom clancy's work over the
years including some of his books and
the many video games that have been
inspired by his work it was about time
that i talked about the man himself
i know this video won't be for everyone
in fact this information is something
that i'd compiled together quite some
time ago but i saw it as more of a
personal piece and decided to hold it
back from completion and upload
but as i've been informed recently there
are a number of people who'd like to see
me complete some of these personal
projects and interests so here it is
for those of you who watch this thank
you
while his work may not have been to
everyone's taste it certainly brought
forward a unique flavor to the
industries it touched
thanks again i hope you enjoyed this and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh